[Music]
foreign
that messaging it doesn't seem to be
resonating with the country what would
you list as the administration's
accomplishments or at the very least why
hasn't this Administration been able to
find that bridge with more voters and
the GOP
well I think that foreign
Rubin this is the Reuben report it is
October 2nd where does the time go in
the year 2023 We Are Back In The Free
State of Florida after a couple days in
Crazy commie California we're live
streaming as always on Rumble YouTube
and locals share subscribe tap that
notification Bell if you want to join us
for the post game show and communicate
directly with me correct me nudge me
query me at set her a join us
reubenreport.locals.com and I'm super
psyched to be back in studio we had an
absolutely great trip it felt like we
were gone for like four months we've
only gone from Wednesday to Sunday but
it felt like a long long time something
you know I always talk about out here in
Florida it's like time goes by fast like
it's working here things are good life
is good functioning government all the
stuff I always talk about Cali is just
and we were mostly in Los Angeles we did
do the debate obviously up in Simi
Valley it's about 45 minutes or an hour
go outside of La proper and the debate
was uh well I shared my thoughts with
you guys the other day the debate was
was stodgy and stiff and everything else
if you want some more of my thoughts on
it you can check out our show from uh
Thursday that we did over at Prairie
View in Los Angeles
um
but La itself like I won't belabor the
point but it is so depressing there uh
it feels to me what uh San Francisco
must have felt like probably about five
years ago like you wander around we went
to West Hollywood Hollywood area
Hollywood Hollywood right Stars the Walk
of Fame all of that stuff it's supposed
to feel like something magical and
incredible and instead it's basically
just homeless people and drug addicts
everywhere everything is closed on Santa
Monica Boulevard just really really
depressing went to my our first little
condo that we ever lived in Little
Little Shack basically and it was just
the whole area which I have such fond
memories of just absolutely decimated so
it was great to get back to Florida and
then on Saturday night I did an event at
The Villages which is a really it was my
first time there it's about 45 minutes
outside Orlando there is an area that
many of you have probably heard of
called The Villages and it is basically
a series of like tiny little Villages or
towns that are for it's probably like a
50-up community like a retirement
community uh where people of a certain
age go to spend their I guess you could
say later years but living in just a
great wonderful atmosphere where they
have everything set up for them and
there's just so many great people there
so I did the Lincoln Day dinner on
Saturday night and it was just great and
thank you to everybody who showed up for
that was really fantastic and anyway we
are back at it so let's get going uh the
theme of today's show is do we want
competency or do we want a show and I
get it that many of us may want to show
and I get it that may we may just get
what we deserve but I think there is a
better way out of this and the other
thing that I was a small part of in Los
Angeles was governor DeSantis was on
Bill Maher I was there I got to talk to
the governor a little bit before about
sort of my thoughts on Bill and how you
can get the the old school liberals who
are moving and Mass to Florida right now
and now voting Republicans I thought it
was a really important moment for the
governor and I'm glad to say he crushed
it so we're going to show you some clips
from that we're going to compare that to
a couple things from Donald Trump over
the last couple days then really dive
into just the utter incompetency or I
would say negligent intentional
destruction of the country by the
Democrats so whether you like the
sadness or you like Trump or you like
them both or you're angry at one it's
like the other guys are just completely
bananas right now and Elon Musk is
basically defending our border he's been
defending Free Speech well now he's
decided to defend our border uh also uh
there's a big fight with the Republicans
right now we have averted a government
shutdown for 45 days we'll get into a
little bit of what's going on with Matt
Gates and Kevin McCarthy frankly if the
government shut down and never came back
I would be just fine with that
but anyway we're going to do all of that
on this Monday here we go so let's just
dive in uh so Governor DeSantis did the
comeback show for Real Time with Bill
Maher as you know
the writer strike went on in Hollywood
for about six months the show had shut
down like all the late night shows did
Bill what was it about 10 days ago said
that he was coming back regardless of
whether they settled the strike and then
about three days later they did settle
the strike so they had a normal uh show
there and the Santa's got the opening
interview that's the one-on-one
interview and uh believe it or not and
I actually was not that surprised on it
because uh it's a lot of what I talk
about on this show uh the Santa Scott
Bill Maher to agree on a lot of stuff
here they are talking about uh taking
out the Deep State and all of the
institutions that have become so eroded
but that's driven by ideology so it's
not just we're having just a
philosophical debate I think woke
ideology is corrupted institutions I
think it's corrupted things like the CDC
with how they handled uh coven with the
nonsense that they did so it's a broader
issue than just a philosophical fight
you keep wanting to get back to that and
I don't blame you because you're right
we're on the same page there and I think
it's it's unfair what they did to you
because you did handle it better
you did handle it better you were right
you were like let's target the people
protect the people who are most
vulnerable and everybody else can go on
with their lives a little better you
open schools sooner and a lot of the
stuff that's come in the information we
have after now we've had a few years to
look at it
you were more right
and they won't give you credit for that
it's the New York credit for me though
it's not about credit for me okay but
about them admitting that they were
wrong right they are setting us up if
this happened again they would repeat
the same Playbook all over again and if
we don't have accountability that's
what's going to happen so I'll bring
accountability so it never happens in
our country again I said the New York
Times did such a Despicable hit piece
okay so we're going to get into that uh
second portion of the clip in just a
moment the reason I wanted to show you
that look I know that you guys know all
that stuff right you know that DeSantis
was great on covid you know that there's
every reason to believe that he would
rain hell down on the agencies in the
CDC and the NIH and all of those things
and he got if he got into office because
he has the track record of actually
doing what he says the reason I wanted
to show you that part specifically was
because Bill Maher was in complete
agreement with him that he was great on
covid so think about how the how
politics may make strange bedfellows out
of people you you've got Donald Trump
constantly lying it is simply a lie and
we just all have to acknowledge it and
you can say it's a good tactical thing
and lying is okay and the ends justify
the means and all that but Donald Trump
every day lying about DeSantis and kovid
and mandates and lockdowns and all of
those things and all his surrogates do
the doing the exact same thing and here
you have Lefty liberal Bill Maher who
I've sadly think never vote for a
republican will never vote for DeSantis
but he at least has the balls to tell
the truth right like they did not give
you the credit you deserve they lie
about you then he starts talking about
the New York Times so let's throw that
the New York Times did such a Despicable
hit piece on you that I saw because
I forget what the lead headline was but
it was basically Ron DeSantis up
the
pandemic and then like at the very end
it says Florida's death rate
overall was better than the national
average now if you're going to do a an
article if you're going to do an article
about Florida and the pandemic shouldn't
that be the lead shouldn't that be the I
mean we're the number one state for in
migration I mean if we did so bad people
would have been leaving Florida people
are coming Wells moving into the state
our economy's done better than any other
large State and education we're now
ranked I think in the top five on most
metrics in education now that wasn't
true when I was a kid growing up in
Florida so we we did it right but what
we did is we understood you can't stop
society because of one respiratory virus
so look I really want to give credit
where credit is due for whatever my
sometimes frustrations are with Bill
Maher and I did chat with Bill I had
about a 15-minute chat with him after
the show and like you know we agreed to
disagree on some stuff and he wanted me
to come over and play basketball the
next thing unfortunately I had to I had
to get going like the point is whether
whether you think he's right about these
things or he's never going to get there
or anything else here he is saying
DeSantis was right about kovid and the
New York times is basically trash when
it comes to how they cover Florida and
him and you have to give credit to that
right you may look at Bill and be
frustrated for all of those reasons that
I just laid out but like credit is due
when someone actually tells the truth
especially when we live in a time that
nobody does tell the truth or at least
so few people uh do anyway they
continued uh and they talked a bit about
Donald Trump and I thought this was
quite good the thing is you did not take
my advice
what was it I was on this show a few
times we talked I said this guy's crazy
to run this time he's what are you 45
years old he just had a birthday right
yeah you could run for the next 20 years
if you were biting the next 40.
okay why run against Trump you're trying
to thread this needle that will never
happen well for a couple reasons you
can't you can't disavow him because you
that's the base and yet you're running
against him and that's why I mean let's
face it Ron if this if campaign was
going well you wouldn't be on this show
oh that's not sure
house so um one I don't think he can win
the election uh I could win the election
two I don't think he could actually get
the job done that we need to do for
example covid I think we need
accountability for what this government
did to this country with the coven
restrictions mandates and lockdowns
Donald Trump is not going to do that he
says he did everything right he says he
saved millions of lives with lockdowns
he claims his mnra shot saved 100
million lives he's not going to clean
house at CDC nihfd or any of that I will
do that I will get the job done and a
lot of other things we do the one thing
about me in Florida and even my critics
will acknowledge if he says he's going
to do something he will follow through
and get the job done so it's about the
country are we going to get the country
turned around or not I don't think he's
a vehicle that that's doing and and I
have been when I supported them on the
things I liked I've said it but I've
been critical about the things that he
didn't do and I'll continue to do that
okay but you
again once again the DeSantis stuff is
easy right he's just telling the truth
the mar thing and I just credited Mar
but now I gotta poke him a little bit if
you were Ron DeSantis or any Republican
why would you take Bill Maher's advice
right like why would you be like oh Bill
Maher said I shouldn't run I should wait
I have a bright future knowing that Bill
Maher is never going to support you it's
also a little ironic because Bill Maher
Rants and Raves about Donald Trump all
day right he's orange Hitler and all of
the stuff right I mean he definitely has
some version of TDS I think that's fair
to say I think I've said that to his
face
um we've discussed it on his podcast so
wouldn't you want to help a guy like Ron
DeSantis who you obviously think isn't
crazy why would you say no don't run now
guy even if I'm not going to support you
uh just bow to the guy that I think is
like the embodiment of evil it just
simply doesn't make sense uh also uh
desantis's answer quickly you know this
thing that he can win the election he
can bring in the new people I'm telling
you that audience and remember these are
left mostly Lefty liberal Hollywood
people some of them are uh you know
tourists that are there to see the show
but to Santa Scott Applause line after
Applause line after Applause line
because people like the truth the truth
is non-partisan so that was nice to see
and then not only win the election but
then actually get the job done again
accomplish the things that he sets out
to do I want to show you one more uh
from the from that interview because it
really they did as much as I think they
could possibly do in the 11 or 12
minutes that it was but Bill tried a
couple times you know what happens is
Bill can't be seen as totally agreeing
with DeSantis on all of these things and
crediting him on covid and crediting him
on the economy here and that everyone's
moving here and all and that the New
York Times is lying about him he has to
try to get him on something so he tried
to get him on backing election deniers
and what do I always say about this when
you're let's say conservative or
whatever when you're a non-lefty and you
go on these shows bring the freaking
seats that the governor did just that
but you campaigned for for election
deniers in 2022. this I do not forgive
well to quote the Godfather I mean
Carrie Lake who said Biden is a
legitimate president
Trump didn't well now she's attacking me
so maybe I did make a mistake there
because uh she's out there saying she's
trying to say that we mandated vacs in
Florida we did the opposite we protected
people even from private mandates so so
that may have been Trump lost the
election right yeah yeah okay so why did
you campaign for people because I wanted
to see Republicans win Key races that's
not a deal breaker issue for you that's
not democracy okay well let's go back to
2016. uh your friends in Hollywood were
cutting ads telling the Electoral
College to to vote against Trump in in
the Electoral College because it was
stolen they said Russia stole the
election for years they said that so
don't act like this is like a unique
thing in modern history of the converse
first of all Ron I have no friends in
Hollywood
you do remember those commercials though
I remember them
look that's really good by DeSantis he
brought the receipts don't sit here and
tell me that no one you know was calling
this election illegitimate let's not
forget guys there's the clip of me on
Club random with Bill saying that
Hillary called Donald Trump an
illegitimate president and he said no he
no she didn't right and we've all you
all know the evidence of that so that's
a great job of DeSantis just turning it
right you guys spent four years
undermining Step in Time impeaching
Donald Trump calling him illegitimate
saying the Russians installed them and
all of that stuff and now because you
campaigned for Carrie Lake Carrie Lake
who used to say Ron DeSantis was the
greatest governor in the country and as
DeSantis rightfully pointed out is now
lying about DeSantis and Florida
um and we've shown some clips of that on
the show last week by the way and then
Kerry Lake I don't even want to get into
this too far she got in my face right at
the at the Republican debate and she was
not happy with me for going after her uh
and then she uh she unfollowed me on
Twitter because you know these people
really they're so brave and so just but
I will call it as I see it and she is an
election denier and and she is a liar
and uh and I hate to tell you Carrie but
Trump is not choosing you as his VP
because he doesn't need to go to the
base anymore he would have to widen it
so okay there you go Carrie Lake we
don't have to talk about Carrie lake
anymore I don't think there's really any
any point on that one uh anyway let's go
with a little let's go a little further
because as I said after the debate
DeSantis can I can show you those clips
of this antis all day long and you all
know it right and everywhere I went over
the last five days people kept saying
the same thing to me everybody was
everybody wherever I went at stores at
restaurants at the debate at the event
that I just did everybody was saying the
same thing which is they're tired of
trump they like the scientists but what
about these polls what about these polls
now look polls are always wrong what
happens after every freaking election
ever they spend days going why were the
polls all wrong right so I'm not hung up
on the polls but what I am hung up on is
that DeSantis for all the goodness has
to figure out a way to separate from the
rest of these guys he's he's up on stage
basically at a audition for other jobs
that's what the other people are doing
and he's the only one auditioning to be
the president of the United States and
Trump is I have no problem saying it
Trump is afraid of him you can say it's
good tactically that Trump isn't there
fine you can say that again do the ends
justify the means what a healthy
democracy as Jordan Peterson has talked
about would a healthy democracy just not
have candidates debating guess what if
Trump
doesn't debate this entire thing and
then becomes the nominee just wait till
Biden says I will not uh debate him
because you know he's mean and scary and
everything else and then one day we will
just have no debates and we will just
have candidates who are installed so
that is the road we are going down if we
don't call out some of this BS now but
all of that being said the santis has
got to figure out a way to break out of
the pack and make it clear that he is
the one guy that will go against Trump
and he is trying to do it and we will
see if enough people will get behind him
on that uh here he is right after the
debate talking about just that I'd say
the final thing Bill he's had a lot to
say about me on social media really
since 2022 right before the midterm
election he started uh he started
attacking me when I was we all
Republicans were supposed to be United
for a red wave no he tried to attack me
and has been doing it a lot you know
it's one thing to do it behind a
keyboard step up on stage and do it to
my face I'm ready for it all right
that's the DeSantis we need that's
that's the type of clip you have to
share with your friends and and that's
when you get into a conversation with a
good decent Trump supporter who there
are millions one of those people who is
the base and maybe is ride or die with
Trump they don't but but wouldn't you
want ideas to be battled wouldn't you
really want the cream to rise to the top
wouldn't you want the guy who's best
suited for this job at the very least he
could defend those ideas and as Brock
just pointed out you know the same
people right now who are so thrilled
that Donald Trump will not debate when
Biden chooses not to debate which I
guarantee he will if it's Trump well sir
if it's DeSantis they'll never put Biden
on stage they'll most likely get rid of
him because the idea that DeSantis young
45 sharp and everything going against
geriatric Crypt Keeper like that ain't
gonna work at all but they'll they'll
stop him from debating at all they'll
stop him from debating Trump and the
very same people right now who are
lauding Trump for his tactical genius
move of never having to defend his ideas
and never debating they will then and
when Biden won't do it they will say
Biden is subverting democracy and you
see he's afraid and he's in his basement
and all of that stuff okay fine one more
on DeSantis uh this is a little more a
little more on the dig on Trump and the
simple truth is and again and I know a
decent amount of you were pissed at me
for talking about it this way but if we
are going to get through this stuff then
we have to have an honest open battle
with all of the warriors on the field
involved in the battle and uh DeSantis
is going after Trump for for the hiding
you just heard president Trump he said
he said said let's partner up you be my
VP would you do it
no I'm running for president we need
somebody that can serve two terms we
need somebody that can win States like
Georgia and Arizona which president
Trump cannot do or did not do even
though candidates like McCain and Romney
had no problem winning those States we
need somebody who and I'm the only one
running including Donald Trump
everything I've promised the voters that
I would do as governor of Florida I've
delivered on we delivered budget
surpluses paying down debt tax cuts
school choice parents rights Banning
Sanctuary cities expanding second
amendment rights all in all down the
line uh I promise and I deliver and
that's really what we need because the
country is in Decline we can't just
manage this decline a little bit better
than the Democrats we need to reverse
the decline but that means you've got to
get in there and actually get all this
stuff done and I'm the candidate that's
that can get do that and that's why I'm
running and I think that with all due
respect to Donald Trump uh we're not
going to beat the Democrats by adopting
Joe Biden's basement strategy you can't
just be missing in action you got to
show up you got to earn people's votes
and if you're not willing to do that
voters will take notice as we get closer
to these
all right yeah Ruth I don't have to
contort myself now he doesn't have to
contort himself Maria Bartiromo who's
very friendly with Trump done many uh
interviews are from She's agreeing with
all that because it's just true and we
really have to think about it this way
we need to be honest with ourselves the
the Trump base needs to be honest with
itself do you want to be just involved
in the show and the destruction and the
name calling and the ridiculous posting
on Truth social and then lose the
election because if you believe and I
believe Donald Trump when he says that
he believes that the election was stolen
so if you Donald Trump and all of the
Trump supporters believe the election
was stolen you got to tell me why they
wouldn't steal it again or you got to
tell me what you've done for them not to
steal it again I have heard neither I
have heard Trump say nothing on what he
would do he complains that they stole it
but he hasn't said how he's going to
stop them right I haven't seen any work
on the ground done related to any of
that so you also would then have to
explain well why wouldn't they just do
it again they did it once but this time
no no this time they're not going to do
it why would they do it again the thing
that they did
makes no dents okay that's number one uh
the other point that the scientists made
there that was quite good is is there
any reason let's say they didn't steal
the election right okay so let's say it
was all legit and Biden got 81 million
votes and Trump got 75. is there any
reason to think Trump would get more
votes this time now you might say I'll
try to do it as cleanly as possible you
might say well the Democrats have are
now come across as more radical and
Biden seems really old so maybe there's
some like soft support there so a
certain amount of people won't vote
maybe but we just saw what happened with
no red wave in the midterms right so
there's not a lot of argument on that uh
also the fact that as DeSantis pointed
out Trump lost Georgia and Arizona you
got to get him how are you magically
going to win them
McCain and Romney got them so how are
you going to do that where are the new
Trump voters I don't know where they are
I know a lot of people who are tired of
it but I don't know anyone that in the
last two years yeah there's a decent
amount of people who are frustrated with
the way the the uh government is going
after him and that's completely
legitimate but I don't know any new
person who is suddenly and please find
them for me if you can and I'll gladly
have someone on the show who suddenly
was like I was a Biden supporter
or I didn't vote and now I'm going to
support Trump after all this no but
there's a lot of people breaking away
from it and one more thing which is the
amount of people who I would argue
mostly unjustly completely hate Trump no
matter what they will walk over glass to
vote against him so Trump being the
nominee causes the Democrat vote to go
up anyway I think I've made a case here
but let's go a little bit further
because Trump who mostly has been
campaigning from his basement that is
just true guys yes he shows up at a
pizza place and throws pizza at people
every now and again but he pretty much
isn't campaigning he's writing on Truth
social all day uh he did go to Iowa
because he's realizing actually and I
heard this from an Insider in Iowa over
the weekend that the Iowa polls are
making no sense and the on the ground
support for Trump seems to be collapsing
so he actually did go to Iowa
um and listen to what he said here uh
related to remember remember Mexico was
gonna pay for the wall well he basically
admitted that was complete nonsense so
when you hear these lunatics back there
say
Trump didn't get anything from Mexico
well you know there was no legal
mechanism because I said they're going
to help fund this wall but there was no
legal mechanism how do you go to a
country you say by the way I'm building
a wall hand us a lot of money
do you know how many times in 2015 and
16 and even beyond that he said that
they were going to pay for the wall now
Mexico did do some things like put some
troops there but clearly that didn't
work that much but why if he knew that
there was no legal mechanism to get them
to pay for it why did he keep saying it
or is it that he just lies and a certain
amount of people just like those lives I
mean we could show you an endless
compilation of that sort of thing but
here he is back in 2016.
believe me Mexico is paying for the wall
[Applause]
not even a doubt not even a doubt and
now he admits that there was no way they
could pay for the wall so okay you can
be angry at me
and I have no doubt that the Trump
people are angry at me I am just telling
you the truth so you can decide whether
you think knowing the truth has any
bearing on how you want to vote or what
you want to think about things but he
was basically saying I knew there was no
way
and you know so what and he knows that
people a certain amount of people will
still support him uh here he is talking
about how much border or wall he
actually built this is also in Iowa
talking about how much he actually built
and it's a little little screwy I'll
give you some numbers after
and then I built a 40-foot wall a
50-foot wall or a 30-foot wall on top
they say that was a renovation that
doesn't count these people I'll tell you
what they have I'll tell you they have a
great line of that's one thing
I can that was a renovation
like sloppy Chris Christie oh he only
Built 56 miles of wool because there was
some wood laying on the ground so they
call that a renovation we built almost
500 miles of wool even the Obama
Administration says it in this that's
but we had
we've totally fulfilled man it's getting
harder for me with those clips like I'm
just tired of the way he speaks and and
even the language and whatever like it's
just it is what it is so let me just
give you some real numbers here these
are hardcore numbers please fact check
me on this there are
1954 miles of border between the U.S and
Mexico the Trump Administration built
458 miles of wall but the discrepancy
here seems to be that yes there were
some things that were sort of built and
some wood there so they call those
Renovations Donald Trump's
Administration only Built 52 new miles
and then there was another 400 that they
can call Renovations that were or we're
not going to get done or anything else
but in essence
458 total miles of wall were completed
under Donald Trump where they were
whether they were brand new 52 miles or
whether they were the 400 whatever you
400 or so renovated miles anyway the
point is
under 500 miles of Border War wall were
built the Mexicans did not pay it and
it's basically less than a quarter of
our total uh of our total barrier our
total border between the U.S and Mexico
now I will give Trump for credit on this
by having some of the rhetoric that he
had related to immigration it kept
people away right people didn't want to
take the crazy dangerous Trek to only
think that
whether it was true or not a wall was
there or they were going to get turned
around or anything else but in terms of
what he actually did and what he would
what he said he was going to do it is
just true and I voted for him and I
might vote for him again I'm just trying
to tell you what is true he did not
build a wall that was functional in any
way and he certainly didn't build enough
of it to make it work what is the proof
of that well the proof of that is on
this show and on many other shows you're
not seeing it much on mainstream except
for Fox we are seeing videos now every
single day of the Border being ransacked
now I would say that the Biden
Administration is negligent in what they
are doing because they were literally
opening up doors they're cutting barbed
wire they are welcoming people in and
telling them to go wherever they want
and a whole bunch more so what's
happening now and this is the disconnect
between mainstream media and the online
media is people are now seeing it
they're seeing it and they're going wait
a minute on one hand I've got the
administration and the elderly man
pretending to be president
Pierre telling us that the border is
secure and then I'm seeing all of these
videos where it clearly is not secure so
Elon Musk our renaissance man of the day
who's saving free speech on Twitter and
sending us to Mars and building Teslas
and everything else he decided all right
I'll also take my phone and go to the
Mexican border here he is in Eagle Pass
Texas doing a live stream on Twitter
explaining what the hell's going on down
here
yeah so here we are at Eagle Pass uh and
we're going to be meeting with uh
the sort of major the major officials uh
uh and uh law enforcement are
responsible for the water and
um Andrew's here directly from them and
see it see exactly what's going on uh
for yourself so so basically we're
seeing uh unprecedented at the all-time
highs and increase it it's ready it's
not in just one area it's it's not just
like it's just one city or one town and
not even one State anymore you know it's
not we're talking about New York today
but Chicago you're hearing it there La
Denver there's all these other places
where it's just spreading just continues
to get bubbling up do you think Elon
Musk might have better things to do with
this time maybe not better maybe that's
not the right word it's important what
he's doing but do you think that when
Elon Musk woke up a couple weeks ago and
was looking at his calendar for the
month he thought oh I'll just head down
to the border and deal with that no he
wanted to do all of the other absolutely
truly incredible things that he's doing
but we need more people to shed light on
this right we need more people to show
us something that's true and give us an
honest assessment of what's going on
here take a look at this image uh this
is Elon at the border and look those are
that's hundreds easily I don't know how
far the picture goes out of frame of
people that are just standing there
waiting to get in and guess what they're
basically all gonna get in I thought I'd
show you some numbers here and here's
where I can give Trump a little credit
uh just like I did a moment ago this is
data from the U.S customs and border
patrol of total migrant encounters so 17
18 and 19. now these are the years that
Trump was president and even 20. you had
310 404 859 and 405
000 uh people uh at the border right so
just by the nature whether the Border
was porous or not just by Trump saying
hey you can't come in less people came
then Biden becomes president and look
what happens to the numbers
1.66 million in Biden's first year
2.21 million invited in second year and
year to date this year 1.8 million so we
will obviously eclipse last year's
numbers on that so the point is that
when you can where you can criticize
Trump is that he didn't get the wall
done and by the way the Democrats were
never going to let him get the wall done
and everything else but this is where
you have to be a better negotiator you
have to be a better executive and all
that Mexico was never ever going to pay
for it but his rhetoric alone does
matter when when a republican gets there
and says
you can't come people hear that across
the world but when a Democrat gets there
and like well the border is kind of open
and we don't know nobody's illegal and
everybody's welcome and all that stuff
the very nature of the rhetoric allows
people to come and then they show up and
they go boy that border doesn't look too
close and there's a nice man in a in a
United States security outfit and he's
going to open up the door for me do we
have to tip these people anyway you got
you got it so the the simple truth here
is that the open border policy that we
are now well you know let me give you
this tweet from Elon because he really
hit it he wrote If New York is already
buckling under the load and has run out
of room what will the situation be like
in a year from now the open border
policy started under Biden two years ago
that policy was not in place under Obama
and Governor hochul is a Democrat not a
republican so this is not some diverse R
political battle it's it is specific to
the current Administration now you might
be reading that going uh wait what what
is is Elon Musk crediting Kathy hokel
for something well believe it or not
Kathy hokel Kathy seaward this woman who
is just about the worst of the worst
when it comes to pretty much everything
she now as governor of New York is
seeing New York City collapse right Eric
Adams basically said get the F out of
this city there's nothing I can do about
it 10 000 people a month coming in I
can't help you well Kathy has had it so
there's a great compilation for video
we're going to show you this back to
back of uh this is December of 21 her
what she was saying about uh illegal
immigration for versus what she's saying
now about illegal immigration
as you know the Statue of Liberty is
inscribed it says give hired
mass is yearning to be free the wretch
is refuse to a teeming Shore and that
statement encapsulizes our values we
want people to come here despite where
they came from or despite the
circumstances that drove them to this
country into this into this state we see
say you are welcome here we are welcome
with open arms and we'll work to keep
you safe we'll not only house you but
will protect you
so our message to the world is
send us your people send us those who
need the uh the cloak of comfort that we
can demonstrate as New Yorkers with big
hearts and open arms and will provide a
safe haven we have to let the word out
that when you come to New York you're
not going to have more hotel rooms we
don't have capacity so we have to also
message properly that Where'd I live at
if you're going to leave your country go
somewhere else but the smarter thing is
to apply for Asylum before you leave
your country
if you're going to leave your country go
somewhere else you see how quickly
they get mugged by reality right six
months or what is it nine months before
that welcome everybody poor huddled
masses come we'll put you in the cloak
we'll hug you we'll give you and
now it's get the F out of here right
don't care where you go but you can't
stay here that woman should be impeached
immediately now I understand New York
and their their state legislature I
lived there for 20 some odd years of my
life it's deeply corrupt it's one party
they love destroying themselves while
the elites gain more power and gain more
money and all that stuff but if you are
a New Yorker I don't know what the hell
you're doing if you're watching this
show if you're a New Yorker still at
this point although I do have some
family members there and I'm working on
it everybody's welcome to Florida my
parents are coming in a couple days uh
you've got to get out because these
people lie about everything they create
the problems and then everyone else
votes them in more and more here's a
little more of Kathy c word because now
reality is hit her in the face and she
wants to do something about it it can't
be done this can be done in a bipartisan
way comprehensive Immigration Form What
specifically do you want numbers people
can commit
well we want them to have a limit on who
can come across the border it is too
open right now
what the border is too open but Joe and
crin Jean-Pierre and everybody else
always says the borders closed Jen sake
every day says the borders closed it's
not open but now you have another
Democrat being like well you people are
all liars and by the way you know she's
not going to reference it but I was one
of the people pushing those lies along
and what happens this video is really
this is I can't make any jokes about
this this is disturbing and uh you know
what I'm going to figure out a way to
help this guy let's let's try to contact
him and I'm sure many other people are
but this is a video of a 95 year old
Korean War veteran his name is Frank
tomorrow talking about how the services
that he's been given 95 year old U.S vet
are being cut okay he is being pushed
out of his nursing home because they're
using it for undocumented workers this
video went viral and everyone should
know this guy's name and we will look
into into helping him take a look at
this but the point of all of this of
course is that once you say oh we want
everyone to come here here we're going
to give you stuff we don't have
unlimited stuff and then what do you do
you literally punish our veterans and
our taxpayers and the good decent
citizens of the United States with this
BS policy
it was very disgraceful what they did to
the people in Island Shores
they gave us
time to get out but they never said when
and they never said they will go and get
a sale and then one day
there's a thing on the board I know the
Son of God you gotta be out by March
15th I think that gave us like a month
and a half to find out where we're going
to go
I thought my suitcases were going to be
on the curb because I'm not that pissed
it wasn't for my daughter they would
have been on the Curve
but that's what it happened and uh
that was it
I said no no no no you're not moving me
and they said yes yes yes we are and it
uh everything was done behind closed
doors yeah and we didn't have a chance
to actually make any attempt to stop
them because there wasn't enough time
I don't even know what to say about that
first off God bless that guy we will if
anyone knows how to get in touch with
him my guess is there's a GoFundMe for
him or something can we can we look into
that after a show
um I mean just absolutely evil and
disgusting 95 years old the fact that
guy still has a smile on his face and
God bless his daughter for taking care
of him I'm sure he's gonna it sounds
like he will be okay but there are there
are probably thousands and thousands of
other veterans and it's not just the
veterans it's the hotel owner it's it's
the guy who honestly pays his rent who
is now in a building with these people
and the crime that will expand because
of all that but now I want to link this
to the bigger picture because the bigger
picture what what is happening right now
is there's all of us online talking
about this stuff and again trying to
give you some hopefully honest
assessment of what's going on right and
then there's the mainstream media that
lies about it calls you racist if you
talk about immigration or anything else
and what does the administration want to
do well it wants to make sure that if
you dare listen to people like me or
people like Russell Brand or people like
Ben Shapiro or Megan Kelly Etc uh that
they will have some ability to control
how much you will be able to listen to
us one of the guys that they're really
not happy with right now is Elon Musk
because not only did he open up Twitter
for Free Speech but he's down at the
border we can't have that because what
would he be an agent of yes you got it
misinformation here's the elderly man
pretending to be president uh going off
on Elon for spreading this information
what about what Elon Musk has done to
Twitter lowering guard rails against
misinformation does that contribute to
it yeah it does look one of the things
that I said to you when I thought I
wasn't going to run I was going to write
a book about the changes taking place
and most of it's directed over the years
for these fundamental changes in society
by changing technology Gutenberg
Printing and the printing press change
the way Europeans could talk to one
another all the way to today where where
do people get their news
they they could they you know they go on
the internet they they they they they go
online they go and you have no notion
whether it's true or not
yo you old buffoon what we are finding
on the Internet is far truer that isn't
to say there aren't rabbit holes there
isn't misinformation and disinformation
but you people have lied about
everything you people have lied about
the Iraq War you people have lied about
covid you people have lied about very
fine people on both sides you've lied
about black lives matter you've lied
about whether boys or girls you've lied
about
absolutely everything
and now some people are waking up to it
so now you want to take out the very
people who are trying to Free People to
find something that is true also the way
the question is phrased by John Harwood
is so orwellian Elon Musk has lowered
the guard rails against misinformation
the real way to be saying that would be
Elon Musk has defended free speech that
would be the honest way of saying it
he's lowered the guard rails and by
misinformation of course they mean
anything that's outside of what we got
want you guys to know but don't worry
guys Joe Biden a man who they obviously
don't let hold the phone he's very
interested in AI also to make sure that
you can't you know find out other
information
I've been Keen I have a keen interest in
Ai and can remain key experts on how to
harness the power of artificial
intelligence for good oh don't worry
guys he's going to harness artificial
intelligence for good uh he has a keen
interest in AI I wish the guy had a
little eye forget about the a little I
would be fine with this guy but this
battle and I think you see the way we
frame the show today all of the BS that
the media shows us and now
the attack on the people that are trying
to do something honest it is escalating
and one of the places that most
depressingly so that is escalating is in
Canada where there is a freaking all-out
assault and it is the obvious extension
of everything that Justin Trudeau and
his government has done uh related to
the truckers and the bank accounts and
everything else there is an assault on
Free Speech in Canada probably the worst
in any Western uh government this is a
tweet from Glenn Greenwald the Canadian
government armed with one of the world's
most repressive online censorship
schemes announces that all online
streaming services that offer podcasts
must formally register with the
government to permit regulatory controls
is that not evil is that not evil guys
do you get it do you get how evil this
is the Canadian government which by the
way has the CBC which the people fund
the people fund the thing to that feeds
them the nonsense then a whole bunch
your people wake up and you get Rebel
news out of Canada you get great
thinkers out of Canada like Jordan
Peterson and Gad said and my buddy Viva
fry you get these independent people
Ezra Levant Etc many people I've had on
the show they start
it doesn't even matter whether they're
telling you the truth or not they just
say something counter to the Canadian
narrative the Canadian government
narrative and now you're gonna have to
register with the government and could
they pull your license could they
silence you could they pressure YouTube
to
suppress you in the algorithm or perhaps
demonetize you well how about uh we
listen to Neil Mohan Neil Mohan is the
new Youtube CEO and he's very happy that
they demonetized Russell Brand Russell
Brand who by the way has not been
convicted of any crime he's just been
accused of some things but they as a
company have decided that he's not
allowed to make a living
Monday on CBS mornings our exclusive
interview with the CEO of YouTube he
talked about a number of things
including his decision to block Russell
Brand from collecting ad money from his
YouTube videos the move was made after
four women accused brand of sexual
assault allegations he denies we asked
bran to respond to YouTube's decision in
the latest allegations but we have not
heard back here's part of Tony's
conversation with Youtube CEO Neil Mohan
we have a Creator responsibility
guidelines
policy where if creators have
off-platform Behavior or there's
off-platform news that could be damaging
to the broader Creator ecosystem you can
be suspended from our monetization
program uh it's impacted a number of
creators and personalities on the
platform uh in the past and that's what
played out in this particular case
around the serious allegation it's an
accusation it's not a police charge it's
not a a legal decision
how do you decide when to step in before
the whole due process has happened we
Endeavor to apply those rules equally
across our entire Creator ecosystem not
playing favorites having them apply to
the content the behavior as opposed to
who the person is lies lies lies lies
there's nothing but lies there and the
fact that what they are saying is what
you do off platform
will dictate whether you can make a
living or be heard on this platform is
so freaking dangerous think how stupid
this is or not it's not stupid it's evil
think how evil this is imagine if there
was a guy
who let's say he actually stole an apple
from a grocery store and he worked at a
shoe store he was a shoe salesman and
for whatever reason he stole an apple
do you think that he should no longer be
allowed to create YouTube videos
see how those things are all wildly
disconnected but that's in essence what
they're saying if you do something we
don't like you wait you're a shoe
salesman who stole an apple you can't
make YouTube videos and that's if the
guy stole the Apple there's no evidence
that Russell Brand did anything it's a
it's besides the point but the idea that
off platform
man it's so dangerous these people are
liars and what are you saying Neil Mohan
so someone could just make up you know
Mohan molested me
well I guess Neil Mohan can't make money
on YouTube but don't worry I'm sure you
make several million to you know have
the the job that you have you
liar these people
there goes our modernization for today I
walked right into that one anyway a
little bit more for you uh there's been
this uh this whole Fiasco related to the
government shutdown and uh I would
connect that all to this because both
sides are kinda Stucky right uh but the
the whole idea of the government
shutdown was the Republicans wanted to
do a little something what do I always
say about Republicans they're kind of
like Democrats but a little bit less
worse but they wanted to do a little bit
something on uh all of this extra
spending and just the nonsense that we
all know that the government does uh so
let's start with uh video of White House
budget director what's her name here
Phoenix roll for me uh Shalonda young uh
talking about some of the very very
scary things that Republicans would do
if they were to cut the budget a little
bit
their bill includes devastating 30
percent Cuts you heard me 30 percent
cuts
and listen to what that means
it would eliminate twelve thousand FBI
agents
almost a thousand ATF agents and more
than 500 local law enforcement
oh my God 30 percent you heard me great
how about 50 percent how about just
start hacking away at this useless thing
that mostly is used to be weaponized
against us also it's really interesting
suddenly the Democrats are very into
people with guns right 12 000 FBI agents
a thousand ATF agents 500 local these
people with guns don't we have to get
these people off the streets people with
guns they're dangerous Jesus but of
course we should be cutting the federal
budget but they try to scare the high
hell out of you about the whole thing
anyway here's a little more context
about the uh The Wider fight this is
from Fox News the House of
Representatives voted Saturday to pass a
short-term spending Bill moving to avoid
a government shutdown if the Senate
adopts the measure house lawmakers on
both sides of the aisle broke out into
Applause in a rare moment of
bipartisanship after a short-term Bill
known as continuing resolution past 335
to 91. the funding patch will last for
45 days past the end of the fiscal year
which concludes at midnight on Sunday
October 1st the bill also includes 16
billion for disaster relief Aid that
President Biden requested over the
summer speaker Kevin McCarthy said on
Saturday it comes after House
Republicans tried and failed to stop us
sorry tried and failed to pass a
separate stop-gap funding bill that
contained conservative policy items like
border security and spending cuts the
national debt reached 33 trillion for
the first time in history in September
amplifying concerns amongst
conservatives that government spending
is out of control so look obviously guys
government spending is out of control so
all they did here was once again and
this is what the government does this is
what the swamp is it kicks the can down
the road it solves no problems we get
more spending we ultimately get higher
inflation the money that is in your
pocket that you worked real hard for
becomes worth less because we give
billions of your dollars to things like
Ukraine and we get in these quagmires
and none of it helps any of us one of
the guys who was fighting against
McCarthy the hardest these 21 Rebel
right-wing Republicans who are trying to
get some
concessions out of the Democrats is
Florida representative Matt Gates uh he
went on Jake tapper's show and said he
has had it with McCarthy and he's going
to try to take him out tomorrow I do
intend to file a motion to vacate
against speaker McCarthy this week I
think we need to rip off the Band-Aid I
think we need to move on with new
leadership that can be trustworthy look
the one thing everybody has in common is
that nobody trusts Kevin McCarthy he
lied to Biden he lied to house
conservatives he had appropriators
marking to a different number altogether
and the reason we were backed up against
the shutdown politics is not a bug of
the system it's a feature Kevin
McCarthy's goal was to make multiple
contradictory promises to delay
everything back us up against shut down
politics and at the end of the day blow
past the spending guard for LC degree
okay so what you're seeing here really
is just sort of part two of remember
that that 15 vote fight to make McCarthy
uh leader in the first place that they
were trying the gate side of things
we're trying to get more concessions out
of him and Gates is basically saying hey
you guys are just running around doing
the same old things that we thought you
were going to do so I'm going to now try
to make sure that you're not the speaker
anymore anyway it's not going to work
McCarthy is going to remain the speaker
there's an interesting inner Trump fight
here because let's not forget Gates is a
trump guy but Trump backed McCarthy and
now the base is angry at gates for going
against McCarthy and McCarthy by growing
government is doing all the things that
are anti-trump try to put that one
together in a chart could we get a
couple arrows going every which way
anyway McCarthy responded on that there
is a lot to get to with you I want to
start though on the
says he's going to
to seek a motion to to Kate he's going
to try to oust you a speaker
of the house that's nothing new he's
tried to do that from the moment I ran
for the office look well this time he
says he's going to keep going may not
get there before the 15th ballot but it
took 15 for Kevin McCarthy he says he's
coming for you can you survive yes I'll
survive you know this is personal with
Matt Matt voted against the most
conservative ability to protect our
border secure our border he's more
interested in securing TV interviews
than doing something he wanted to push
us into a shutdown even threatening his
own district with all the military
people there who would not be paid only
because he wants to take this motion so
be it bring it on let's get over with it
and let's start governing if he's upset
because he tried to push us in a
shutdown and I made sure government
didn't shut down then let's have that
fight
okay so look whether you agree with
Gates on this thing or whether you agree
with McCarthy the point is this is the
same old fight that the government gives
us all the time whether it's Democrats
or Republicans or anything else so what
is the way out of it well how about we
had an executive not a lawmaker how
about we had someone confident wasn't a
showman and how about we had someone who
has a track record of winning and
there's every reason to think he could
win again here's one more of Ron
DeSantis on Real Time with Bill Maher
right they are setting us up if this
happened again they would repeat the
same Playbook all over again and if we
don't have accountability that's what's
going to happen so I'll bring
accountability so it never happens in
our country again I said the New York
Times did such a Despicable hit piece on
you that I saw because
I forget what the lead headline was but
it was basically Ron DeSantis up
the
pandemic and then like at the very end
it says Florida's death rate
overall was better than the national
average now if you're going to do an
article if you're going to do an article
about Florida and all right you got it
we showed it to you before and I just
wanted to drive it home we're a little
tight on time uh because I'm doing Megyn
Kelly show immediately after this but I
want to show you one more thing there
was a time guys when you hear DeSantis
and you're like it sounds so foreign a
guy who's saying what he will do and
there's every reason to believe he will
do it but guess what we used to have
politicians like that there's a video
this is from about 40 some odd years ago
this is uh Chicago mayor Richard Daly
talking about how there was a ton of
looting going on in the city there was
rioting and looting going on in the city
I believe he was a Democrat can you
confirm that for me I'm pretty sure he
was a Democrat it's actually irrelevant
but we will confirm that but listen to
what he was saying in Chicago about
looting and what you would do to keep
Law and Order uh this is again 40 years
ago and we had politicians who actually
believed in Law and Order
I said to him very emphatically and very
definitely
it in order to be issued immediately
under his signature
to shoot to kill any arsonists
or anyone with a Molotov cocktail in
their hand in Chicago to fire a building
because their potential murders
and to issue a police order
to shoot domain or triple anyone looting
any stores in our city
and above all
the crime of arson
is to me the most hideous and
worst crime of any
and should be dealt with
in this fashion I was disappointed to
know that every policeman out on the
beat was supposed to use his own
decision
and this decision evidently
was his
in my opinion he should have had
instructions to shoot arsonist and to
shoot looters
that's how you end a riot and guess what
the riots will come back he was a
Democrat by the way I was right think
how fundamentally different mayor of
Chicago Democrat mayor of Chicago
imagine if anyone in Chicago said that
now imagine if almost anyone in the
country said that now how they would be
treated but the point is it does not
have to be like this guys we can elect
people who will do what they say we can
elect people who believe in rule of law
we can beat the Democrats we can beat
the woke we can beat all of the liars
and the frauds and we can believe beat
all of the people who just want to
distract you while your life gets worse
and their life gets better that is the
plan so let's keep going with that uh
guys unfortunately there will be no post
game show today uh because we we did go
along here and I've got to be on Megan
in about four minutes and frankly I have
to pee uh so uh give me a break on that
one we will make it up to you I'll try
to do something for our locals guys I'll
try to do something on my phone a little
bit this afternoon thanks for bearing
with us uh we'll be on Megan Kelly for
the hour as I said cold close and we'll
see you later thanks guys how would you
say your mental focus is
[Music]
what's focused
foreign
look
[Music]
made in America
I think it's a right for people that bad
and can't Care America is a nation that
can be defined in a single word
I was in foot
corn pop was a bad dude and he ran a
bunch of bad boys wait wait wait all men
and women created by the go you know
this you know the thing it holds near
and dear to you that you uh
um like to be able to
anyway
we went for two reasons
one two
[Music]
foreign